how is the process for you reading a
script as a director different from you
reading script as an actor yeah it's
it's entirely different you know as an
actor your focus is very is very myopic
and and and you know when I when I read
a script as an actor I'm you know
obviously I'm focusing on the character
that they're approaching me to play in
the piece so although i am reading the
entire piece my focus is on is on that
one character because as an actor you
approach you approach the piece from
from the point of view of your one of
your character because you have to and
as a director you know i'm reading the
script as the entire piece because your
your focus as a director is the is is
the entire piece and and and of the
piece as the whole because you're
responsible for the whole thing so so so
you know it really it really comes down
to to the difference in the focus of the
two crafts as a as an actor your focus
is very finite and very in very myopic
and as a director your focus is very
broad and very all-encompassing and it
has to be so for cass and dylan which is
your feature directorial debut how many
times did you read the script before you
said yes to the project I read the
script twice before I said yes to the
project that's all it took I was I was I
was very taken with the opportunity to
to tell this story on a on a grand scale
I was as a young man I I made a journey
from Winnipeg Manitoba to Vancouver
British Columbia with my father actually
yeah when I was about to when I was
about ten years old so I was very
familiar with that with that landscape
and that and how that landscape changes
and and how that how that color palette
chain
as you drive from east to west across
across Canada so I so I you know once I
was invested in once I was invested in
the characters and the story I knew I
knew the story that I wanted to help
visually as well because it because you
know that part of the world and the way
that the way that it changes from the
prairies to the mountains to the to the
coast is is such such a unique and
impressive change you know I really I
really wanted to to impress that upon
people
you